[Musique]
nouvelle édition du journal sur tv fil
78 au cours du prochain quart d'heure
nous allons faire le point sur
l'essentiel de l'actualité locale sans
plus attendre voici les titres de ce
jeudi 29 septembre 2016 le mondial de
l'automobile s'apprête à ouvrir ses
portes à paris vous verrez les images
des nouveautés des principaux
constructeurs des constructeurs présents
dans la plupart sur saint quentin en
yvelines si vous étiez sur la route près
de la vallée de chevreuse hier vous les
avez peut être aperçu après avoir
pâturer plusieurs mois dans la propriété
départementale de chant failli à
milon-la-chapelle un troupeau de moutons
vient de rejoindre magny les hameaux les
explications sur cette transhumance dans
ce journal et puis c'est une tradition à
elancourt la fête des vendanges nous
verrons comment l'association les amis
du passé à elancourt prépare cet
événement qui se déroulera ce week end
et nous débutons par une information qui
concerne la ville du chesnay le maire de
la commune annonce la création d'une
réserve communale de sécurité civile
philippe brillault vient de s'adresser
aux habitants à travers un courrier il
les invite à s'engager pour postuler il
faut être majeur ne pas présenter de
handicap psychique ou physique avoir un
casier judiciaire vierge et accepté le
principe du bénévolat après une première
sélection les candidats recevront une
formation écouter le maire ces personnes
ont déjà été formés pour accueillir les
gens sur une fan zone bien sûr ils n'ont
pas le droit de fouiller les personnes
par contre ils sont amenés à pouvoir
regarder l'intérieur de sacs autres de
pouvoir leur poser des questions il ya
un savoir faire ceci leur a été donné
toujours en présence d'un policier
municipal pas trop loin s'il y avait
besoin de faire plus et puis notre
personnel aussi de la ville et
sensibiliser sur toute cette formation
de sécurité pour l'instant on n'a pas le
temps d'aller plus loin parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de sujets faut aller très vite
sur tous les sujets donc on avance et on
va voir comment nous allons pouvoir
éventuellement
professionnaliser cette réserve
communale de sécurité civile vous le
savez le rapprochement entre le
département des yvelines et le
département des hauts-de-seine est en
cours une structure commune
d'aménagement a même vu le jour si tu
alios
la première réalisation concrète est
même sorti de terre à rocquencourt le
reportage est signée maxime le maine
pour le conseil départemental des
yvelines
les premiers logements de l'opération
coeur de bourg à rocquencourt ont été
livrés l'occasion pour pierre bédier de
rappeler aux maires du département la
nécessité de construire dans les
yvelines pour les yvelinois évidemment
mais également pour accueillir de
nouvelles populations
la difficulté pour les maires bâtisseurs
c'est que de nouveaux habitants c'est
certes de nouveaux impôts mais c'est
d'abord de nouveaux équipements et on
n'a pas toujours l'argent pour
construire les écoles les crèches et
donc le département à travers un contrat
spécifique donne aux maires des
subventions pour pré équipés en
attendant l'arrivée des nouveaux
habitants jean-françois pommery fait
partie de ces maires bâtisseurs pour
cette opération il a été accompagné par
site alios l'aménageur foncier des
hauts-de-seine et des yvelines nous
avons cherché à travailler avec des
personnes qui étaient proches de proches
de la commune qui connaissait nos
problèmes et qu'ils pouvaient s'adapter
à nos besoins problème de taille
rencontrées par les équipes une partie
de la zac du bourg et dans le périmètre
du château de versailles certains
bâtiments relève donc du code de
l'urbanisme et d'autre du code du
patrimoine
si l'aménageur n'était pas un aménageur
qui était soutenu par le département
soutenu par l'établissement public
foncier je pense qu'ils demandent l
addition à la ville et partait juste est
trop compliqué on a perdu un an de
discussions avec la drac pour savoir
comment on allait lever cette réserve du
code du patrimoine grâce à l expertise
de sites al youm les premiers habitants
peuvent donc intégrer leur logement dès
aujourd'hui
le mondial de l'automobile va ouvrir ses
portes samedi plus d'un million cinq
cent mille visiteurs sont attendus
jusqu'au 16 octobre les plus grands
constructeurs du monde présentent leurs
derniers modèles et ses constructeurs
sont justement basée à saint quentin en
yvelines du centre de recherche de
renault à guyancourt au siège de
mercedes france à montigny le bretonneux
est les yvelines premier département
automobile de france de nombreuses pme
sont impliqués dans la production à nous
y reviendrons plus en détail dans nos
prochaines éditions pendant que vous
apercevez justement quelques unes des
vedettes du salon qui côtoient les
véhicules de luxe d image signée patrick
jacques de dixmude et puisque nous
parlons automobile intéressons nous à
présent à l'automobile de demain à quoi
ressemblera le véhicule du futur loin
des voitures volantes ce sont plutôt les
énergies utilisées qui focalise
l'attention des chercheurs et des
étudiants à saint quentin en yvelines
l'estaca prépare d'ailleurs ses élèves
focus sur cet établissement c'est signé
haussmann vendeur de
voiture autonome électriques ou encore
intelligence artificielle
voici les sujets d'étude de la voiture
de demain sur lequel planchent les
enseignants chercheurs de l'estaca mais
le projet le plus ambitieux c'est la
voiture autonome je vais que l'otan mais
nous on cherche donc à le à l'oeuf à
faire fonction de véhicules dans un
situation de conduite urbaine
périgordins son intervention du
conducteur pour assurer un confort et
puis augmenter la sécurité des usagers
du de la route et pour créer la voiture
du futur il ya les
enseignants-chercheurs bien sûr mais
aussi les 1800 étudiants de l'estaca
grâce aux associations de l'université
ils peuvent laisser libre cours à leur
imagination comme avec cette association
qui a créé une voiture de course pour
des compétitions
l'association c'est un moyen de
d'appliquer les cours découvre en école
d'ingénieur rester au rhic et faire
partie d'une association comme celle ci
permet de pratiquer en fait mais
cependant on apprend de nous mêmes on se
renseigne beaucoup et on est beaucoup en
autonomie le record du monde par exemple
en de tout véhicule électrique ont fondu
et détenus par une forme formula student
donc c'est une seconde 6 0 à 100 donc ce
sont des voitures 4 c'est leur force
quand une très bonne agilité en virage
contrairement à 10 ans et des projets
fous de l'estaca intéresse des
professionnels comme psa renault ou
encore fiat qui n'hésite pas à recruter
les élèves dès la sortie de l'école
du véhicule de demain à la transhumance
des moutons le département est plutôt
contrasté territoire contrastée et cet
après midi hier après midi plutôt un
troupeau de moutons a rejoint magny les
hameaux à la démarche un fort impact sur
l'environnement précision avec camille
lambert et nicolas landry
ce sont des habitués de la montagne les
voilà désormais à magny-les-hameaux 11
mouton est élu domicile à côté du parc
des sports jacques anquetil avec une
mission simple et écologique pâturer et
remplacer des machines parfois limité
intellectuellement une tondeuse ça fait
que avancé alors qu'un bouton ben ça
al'avantage de réfléchir parce que bath
a un cerveau par exemple ils mangent pas
les orchidées ils mangent pas les
narcisses les primevères donc ça fait
des prairies à fleurs plus écologique
plus économique le pâturage naturel est
une pratique devenue fréquente dans de
nombreuses communes pour s'installer à
magny les hameaux les moutons ont
parcouru près de 2 km en ville avec pour
berger une quinzaine d'enfants déjà par
rapport à la nature parce que vont y
voyant nature d'un autre un autre oeil
et puis
ils sont vraiment obtenant habitué à
avoir du bruit des voitures des
tracteurs des camions qui ne pense pas
que la moto on peut à moutons ou une
chèvre on peut la mener pour simplement
tondre la pelouse de jardin chez papa
pour l'occasion les enfants étaient
également invités à réaliser des nids
pour les oiseaux avec de la laine une
après-midi forcément pédagogique pour
tous
nous restons dans les traditions avec la
fête des vendanges c'est à elancourt
chaque année une récolte est organisé
grâce aux quelques pieds de vigne
plantés derrière la ferme du mousseau ce
sont des élèves de la commune qui seront
d'ailleurs est mis à contribution nous
avons rencontré l'association des amis
du passé qui perpétuent ce rite
l'heure est aux vendanges elancourt
toile les amis du passé d'elancourt
prépare la récolte prévue ce dimanche 2
octobre elle rassemblera les élans
courtois autour des vignes de la ferme
du mousseau notamment avec la
participation des enfants de l'école
maternelle du berceau ils vont fouler
égrappé prêcher boire du jus de raisin
et ils auront droit bien un petit goûter
offert par les amis du passé bien mérité
pour l'association c'est le moment de
partager les connaissances et les
difficultés de la pratique viticole il
faut entretenir les disons les branches
enlever les grandes feuilles et veiller
à ce que justement les grappes qui sont
en train de pousser ne tombent pas sous
le coup de la maladie et donc il faut
traiter comme dans toute la france avec
le mauvais temps il eu beaucoup de
maladies beaucoup de groupes qui sont
malades regarder certaines sont très
mûrs et par contre certaines sont encore
à peine à l'état vert avec son vin rosé
le clos mousseau et l'encours est
partagé entre modernité et ruralité nous
avons des vignes à elle en cours depuis
le haut moyen âge et donc non continuer
à perpétuer cette tradition ça c'est
pour s'inscrire dans la tradition de la
commune ensuite c'est bien entendu
symbolique est important parce que la
vigne le raisin le jus de raisin c'est
la sève de la terre c'est ce qui
rapproche l'histoire des longs cours et
de ses paysans de la vie moderne
d'aujourd'hui
rendez vous ce dimanche 2 octobre à la
ferme du mousseau à partir de 10h pour
ramasser le raisin et boire le vin élan
courtois avec modération
culture est tout d'abord cette
initiative d'hélium c'est un
regroupement de quelque 80 artistes qui
depuis à 2005 intervient au coeur du
parc naturel régional pour promouvoir
l'art et les artistes ou encore
favoriser rencontres échanges et actions
parmi ces actions d'envergure un
parcours il se tiendra dans les
prochains jours la présentation de
mélanie poker
derniers préparatifs pour marie-pierre
d'une eau pour les parcours d'ateliers
elle prépare un ensemble de cette offre
fait de différentes matières la
plasticienne fait partie des quatorze
artistes yvelinois à ouvrir leurs portes
de leur lieu de création c'est
le moment d'avoir le regard du public
sur ce que l'on fait parce que si on
travaille tout seul dans son atelier
tout le temps
et on donne des choses qui vont être
vues à l'extérieur sont qu'on soit là
c'est pas la même chose que travailler
recevoir des gens à découvrir aussi ses
sculptures en stéatite activités
principales de l'artiste depuis
maintenant 10 ans c'est le voyage dans
la pierre j'aime beaucoup j'aime
beaucoup
l'élément pierre travailler la pierre
taper faire
de quelque chose de brut en faire
quelque chose de lisse en faire quelque
chose de police quant au travail en
stéatite
l'artiste accueillera chez elle le temps
de ces parcours la photographe catherine
gendron et son travail autour de ces
villes
depuis le 24 septembre à la maison félix
vous pouvez découvrir les oeuvres de
bernard perron cet artiste peintre qui a
réalisé sa première toile à 16 ans et
aujourd'hui c'est sa petite fille qui a
organisé cette exposition à montigny le
bretonneux à décorateur à la télévision
pendant plus de trente ans il est devenu
producteur d'un magazine sur l'écologie
l'a pris sa retraite en s'installant
près de la méditerranée un cadre qui lui
a inspiré la plupart des toiles exposées
et que vous venez de voir elles sont à
découvrir jusqu'au 2 octobre on écoute
justement bernard perron
je dessine beaucoup beaucoup je fais
énormément de croquis et je sais déjà
comment je vais interpréter au moment je
vais attaquer la couenne donc je fais
photo pour mémoriser et ensuite je
retourne au fur et à mesure de
l'évolution du tableau je me déplace une
fois deux fois pour vérifier un petit
peu les couleurs si suis dans l'esprit
s'il ya des choses qui me choquent qui
gêne je suis animé par une espèce de
flamme de la couleur de delà de la
violence de du rythme et c est la
facilité d'emploi de
de l'acrylique permet effectivement
d'aller plus vite dans
qu'on ressent
merci de nous avoir suivi tous nos
reportages sont à revoir sur le
www.tv5monde.com vos commentaires sur
les réseaux sociaux ont rendez vous au
18 heures l'endive pour un nouveau point
complet sur l'actualité locale et puis
n'oubliez pas à l'hebdo ce week end
invité fil rouge pour commenter
l'actualité de la semaine ce sera arnaud
richard le député udi des yvelines qui
va remettre un rapport sur l'accueil des
migrants au gouvernement
[Musique]